did you ever cheat
it's really time to drink
this one is lost Bishop
who are you two and how do you know each
other I'm Matthew I'm Kay my name is
Erica my name is Delvin we're High
School sweethearts we dated for three
years and then now we're just friends
are you friends yes occasionally hook up
foreign
[Music]
sometimes two people are friends with
benefits other times people are just
friends with complications
I think that's what these two are
friends with complications
that's good that's good hey that's good
I think a lot of you need to change your
Facebook status they're friends with
complications right now you know what a
friends this complications is when two
people are [ __ ] with a whole
emotional scene everything is confused
oh yeah because friends with benefits to
know this idea that you guys are friends
yeah but y'all just [ __ ] on the side
like just chill most of the time it's
not dead it's not that there's always a
bit of complication you know some some
Felix Slytherin again talking about um
we were supposed to be just [ __ ] it
turns out you [ __ ] my feelings how
you doing yeah yeah yeah what you
thought you was putting your dick inside
me while I was putting some love inside
you how you doing girlfriend and so
that's where the complications come in
turns out it's not just physical they
get a little bit deeper and I ain't
talking about the dick who broke up with
who and why
she looked like
yeah imagine if whereas Waldo went to an
lgbtq March and you had to find them
[Music]
is she not while she wanted the decoys
you know yes you know the only ones
wearing the same outfit just staring at
the [ __ ] you know when you say some
[ __ ] perfectly those is that right
amount of
that was that you broke up with me
because you saw me as a brother I
actually avoided him for a month before
actually breaking up with him I'm so so
sorry about that and I I'm still so
forgiven he broke up with me because I
sent him a picture
with my friend's brother with his arm
around me or something
which was completely harmless I felt
like she intentionally sent it to set me
off friends with complications you would
like once again you're a wizard Abba Hey
listen
it's not that I'm a wizard
you know what it is you feel Vibe with
some [ __ ] whatever no you know what it
is what is it
is that most friends with benefits are
friends with complications
I didn't predict anything I just played
the odds I'm mad at it someone says
they're friends with benefits I'm like
there's some nonsense going on here one
of you [ __ ] are lying to
yourself you wrote you roll the dices
exactly Snake Eyes you broke up with me
why well uh
you were dating someone else oh so was
there cheating that happened yes she yes
no you can't even deny that there was
cheating my man's My Maids is really
excited to tell this story he saw the
way he set it up oh why did you break up
with me oh um well it was because you
were dating someone else while you were
dating me yeah you remember that time
what caught you [ __ ] another person
and that's why she was not in
relationship with me anymore and that's
how she broke up
yeah my man is excited to tell this
story because he could always hold that
[ __ ] over her head men's look at her
just smiling she don't not give no [ __ ]
you know how I found out about this too
I'm with a friend and she goes you don't
deserve people who make out with random
people in bathrooms and I'm like
what are you talking about and then you
broke up with me over text the next day
yeah that was fun
yeah the pettiness is yay yeah that was
fun that was a great time yeah I loved
High School
oh yeah remember that time were you
cheated on me with everybody on the
football team basically going rounds
their friends in the face and then when
there were no more footballs you were
taking little balls to the face yeah and
then I had to hear about it from the
girls in the bathroom as they wrote it
on the wall and everyone got to read it
before me they said you need to read
this right now yeah and then you broke
up with me the next day yeah high school
I miss it if we were to date now do you
think we would work out
I think we would we've like grown up
together and we really like know each
other so I think we would do a lot
better I agree with that it would be
good it would it would be good we are
the least compatible out of everyone
I've dated like the least can that's
just what your horoscope says bro no
what do you mean you know we obviously
get along really well and we
know each other we live together
and we argue we do argue a lot is it
weird living with each other
no I don't know
whoa
y'all are not even friends with
complications y'all are just
complications
y'all live together there are
complications hey man I don't heard of
some weird [ __ ] this but a woman
cheating on me and then later on
becoming my friend and she out there
taking other dicks and then and then
that's my that's on the new level
that's on the new level God damn I like
having someone there yeah like we have a
romantic friendship connection where
romantic things
take your [ __ ] and go
oh wait it says Pula sir this is a
sickness you smell that [ __ ] right they
go out on dates while she's taking
another month's semen he has brought the
napkin and cleaned her up she said
now that you have had dinner let us go
out for desserts my friends
I like chickens but I do not enjoy
listening to Cox
he says I'm a fire this one is lost
we're okay being like doing those
romantic things going out on dates
holding hands cuddling but there's
nothing sexual there at all like we
sometimes kiss when we're drunk but it
feels like I'm kissing a family member
my friends
stick let us all gather together we have
to right now
[Applause]
no no no no we need something stronger
oh we are going to go back to Our Roots
huh we have heard of voodoo we are going
to call on The Mod Spirits like
this one is lost
Bishop Hazard look at this one that
that's [ __ ] up they are kissing they
are holding hands and then this one
finish one sentence Oh it feels like a
family member you have chosen to have a
child not named self-respect oh that's
[ __ ] no no the idea of dignity has left
your boat oh never was there huh the
idea of self-esteem has come into
existence and then been evaporated like
Thanos a committed suicide this is
disgusting
ah
this this we don't want it in Uganda
keep it away
this is why the West they are going to
lose what immature things did I do when
we dated
refused to tell your parents for like
seven of the eight months yeah I was
under the impression that I wasn't
allowed to date anyone this one she's
she's the seller or the fish I can't
tell they call this one the fatty tuna
it is quite dish do you ever had this
one eh I tried it raw what
did you ever cheat
it's really time to drink
this one asked the question knowing the
answer he knew the answer he knew ain't
this the same girl
that was taking a picture with her
friend's brother and put it in and then
he asked if you ever cheated she got her
that's the one
Hey listen listen listen I ain't got
nothing against the Sun but girl you
Shady there's people who thought that
you were with them when you were with me
do you think we've improved in the
bedroom since we've dated
yes yes of course when I had my first
time
it wasn't you and who was it it was
Daryl
oh he must use his mouth yep
yeah I was bad at that back then yep
what negative things did your friend say
about me when we dated they would say
like your cheater
you don't treat me right but
mostly that you're just selfish do you
remember what I look like naked I never
found out you never did this is
something that you don't know about me
but I was sexually assaulted by a
stranger when I was a really little kid
um
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry not Now's
the Time you decided was the moment to
say that [ __ ] I'm so sorry I didn't mean
to laugh first off him saying that kind
of felt like it came out of nowhere but
maybe there's a reason why but her
replying awful that sounds terrible
is so crazy
it's like if a girl told me she was
great I wouldn't be like
that sounds so terrible like how do you
count
awful
getting dildos that's such a terrible
experience coming out of that moment
like I was really little and the main
thing popped in my head was just like I
should be more careful
which has led to a lot of just anxiety
over uh
not being fully closed at all times
do you think I've gotten better or worse
looking into High School
it's all downhill from here I like you
like in your grown man era like I like
you a little thicker like your beard you
had such a baby face you two are single
uh yeah
the way you look at each other
are there still feelings here
oh it's left well you always love him
and she's always pretty she's been
pretty ever since so
have you ever considered getting back
together I mean if we're not with
someone in 10 years or whatever then
we'll probably just get married but
nothing like we would have girlfriends
on the side and the last time we
seriously thought about it is when I had
broken up with my baby's dad which was
three years ago now but he wasn't ready
definitely was not
what did our relationship teach you it
definitely just taught me like if you
need something say it yeah because as
much as I like to like tease you about
the fact that you never kissed me that
was something I very much wanted that I
never told you you helped me to realize
like my value my worth you're always
telling me how much I've grown how proud
you are of me you always point out the
positive things about me
it's taught me a lot about what I want
what I don't want in myself how to go
into my next relationship and not put my
insecurities and Trauma or whatever that
is on other people
I do feel bad about some of the things
so
yeah
a lot of things it taught me a lot of
things do you still love me as a friend
yeah I'd agree on that I still have a
lot of platonic love for you nice and
like it meant so much to me that you
were at our wedding and I'm just glad to
still have you in my life yeah do you
still love me I love you so much uh uh I
mean in a friend way but I still love
you to death and I think that's better
than anything else I love you too
[Laughter]
oh yeah I love you so much I love you so
much too of course I love you
okay I can't watch this
are you so all right let's watch this
last time hey man what'd I take away
from this video some people got some
weird ass relations bro
and maybe maybe maybe
foreign
maybe this is some of y'all friendships
maybe y'all got weird that was wild that
was wild as [ __ ] I don't even know how
that that's functioning but whatever it
is what it is I guess yeah let's say
what you guys think in the comments
below that was wow yeah